[Upbeat music begins]
Our research focuses on AI and
machine learning for processing
both biomedical text and imagedata.
Using machine learning and AI techniques, we address a set of different problems.
Sothese are different examples.
We find that it's increasingly difficult for individual
researchers to keep up with the rapid growth
of the biomedical literature. We're talking about
over a million articles in PubMed every year and
that means two or three papers every minute.
Wedeveloped a new search algorithm called "Bestmatch".
Our priority is to put the most relevant
papers at the top of their search results in the
first page or in the second page, because
that's where most of the user action is,
and this algorithm is used in PubMed by millions
of users on a daily basis.
The second example is our response to the COVID-19 pandemic. At the
beginning of the pandemic, it was
difficult to locate all the papers on COVID-19 because the term
"COVID-19" was not used by the research community
until later in that year. As a result, there are
many different expressions used in the literature
to refer to the COVID-19 pandemic. So a simple
keyword search would miss many relevantpapers.
In response, we put together a database
called "LitCovid" using machine learning and,
in particular, text classification algorithms, that
go beyond keyword matching, that would find
all the papers relevant to COVID-19 regardless what
kind of expressions were used by the authors.
My last example is our joint work with our clinical
researchers at the National Eye Institute.
We developed an AI tool called "DeepSeeNet" formation
diagnosis and prognosis in retinal diseases suchas
age-related macular degeneration. Not only can
we use retinal images for predicting eye diseases,
we can use retinal images to gain insights
for other systematic diseases in other parts
of the body. In one of the recent works, we used
retinal images to predict heart attack with very
high accuracy and right now we are pursuing a
dissimilar project where we use retinal images
to predict brain diseases such as dementia and
cognitive function decline.
In the long run, what we really aim to do is to teach computers to read
and understand scientific papers like scientists,
to interpret x-rays or retinal images
like radiologists and ophthalmologists,
for disease diagnosis at a speed and at a
accuracy that's above and beyond human ability.
[Upbeat Music]
[Music fades to silence]